after doing it for seven years it was a
dual edge sword I was relieved to be
done but I was also disappointed that we
didn't have a chance to finish
the ark The Narrative it felt early it
felt like we hadn't done that we hadn't
achieved that yet with where we stopped
and then the next thing was just how you
know you shoot these things and you do
this work
kind of in a bubble like in the theater
you you know you have an audience and
you you can feel them reacting and
but sometimes with these TV shows you
don't know you don't know what's out
there and you don't realize
the extent of the support you have and
it was I was really really moved
by how upset the fans were that we got
canceled and and how they rallied to get
us to finish our story and that was that
was a great feeling